peu
[Musique]
pour
auradou
terre martyrs auradou terre du désespoir
chaque rue chaque maison chaque pierre
est un cri aux tristesse en avançant
dans ce village détruit
tu as rempli mon coeur pourtant on se
dit juin 1944 oradour charmante bourgade
de la haute-vienne thurillet sous le
soleil
je n'ai pas trop mal pour moi c'est le
soleil une femme d'oradour porta sur
elle ce message une lettre qu'elle
devait postée le jour même de la
tragédie résolution de ne jamais faire
de mal aux autres
écrivait une petite victime de 11 ans
sur son carnet d'écoliers où il y aura
dourthe huriet thurillet du rire joyeux
de cette terre limousine mollement
étalés entre mais raymond avec ses
prairies vertes ces oiseaux dans les
arbres lourds comme des prunes
hélas quelques heures ont suffi pour
anéantir
tu n'es plus que cendres et ruinent
tendon leurs bras décharnés verra ciel
nu
mais nous nous sommes at-il pas entendre
encore comme en écho la voix de tout ce
bris dans la tourmente de cet holocauste
monstrueux par celle des rescapés qui
témoignent aujourd'hui le 10 juin 44
il était environ deux heures deux hommes
-5 ou -10 lorsque les allemands sont
arrivés sur la place étant réfractaire
déjà n'diaye jeunesse j'étais comme vous
fait ça faisait environ trois mois
j'ai vu d'ici deux rassemblements faire
sur la place et alors là un père me dit
paul il faut partir d'ici parce qu'ils
vont fouiller les maisons
je suis parti dans mon atelier et un
menuisier un spa j'avais les
transmissions découvrent qu'ils
passaient dans des trappes en termes
amis là dedans
wima recouvert de copeaux pour que
personne ne me voyais mon frère qui est
avec moi et 20 seulement 18 ans au bout
d'un certain temps
mon père revienne diaz que ça va j'ai
dit charles
il pleure il va me faire ramasser alors
il a pris mon frère a dit viens puisque
touareg qui va sortir avec nous je n'ai
perdu mon frère monsieur le pas plus que
mes parents au bout d'un certain temps
cette année les coups de feu et puis
alors un renflement je me demandais ce
qui se passait j'ai levé légèrement la
trappe c'est là où j'ai aperçu toute la
maison en flammes
et là mon premier instant que ça a été
vite d'aller sauver les papiers ce qui
pouvait relâcher notre précieux de
valeur mais là j'ai reçu la première
rafale de fusil mitrailleur de
mitraillettes fois par deux petits
jeunes qui paraissait avoir environ 17
ans il y avait juste une palissade qui
nous séparait de se rentrer aussitôt la
première rafale dans l'atelier une
deuxième fois j'ai profité du moment où
ces deux jeunes qui me surveillait
tourner un peu le dos pour sortir de mon
atelier me cacher dans des grands shows
et l'atelier c'est tout écraser rien ans
qui venait jusqu'à la paris sat qui a
dit caputi la pensée sans doute que
j'étais mort quoi que j'étais sous les
décombres j'ai attendu un petit moment
alors là j'ai appelé un vieux voisin que
je dis monsieur le tour savez vous sont
mes parents me dit mon petit tu sais
faut plus les chercher c'est toute une
volée c'est tous massacrés alors je suis
passé chez lui où je me suis mis dans
des squares sonné j'ai attendu un petit
moment le temps qu'il aille fait une
ronde pour voir s'il y avait des
sentinelles alentours en bout d'eux
mêmes dit tu sais je peux t'en aller je
vois personne mais à ça il m'a dit ça
tire partout faut faire attention
alors là je passe d'un jardin à un autre
et je vais me mettre à
entre des ruches d'abeilles est né
malgré les maisons qui s'écrasait qui
venait pas mal de gerbe de flammes
j'ai réussi à gagner le cimetière où je
suis resté dans un état vaut jusqu'à 5
heures du matin si j'ai gagné le village
la déborde à trois kilomètres où j'ai
retrouvé bien sûr mes anciens camarades
dont certains qui étaient blessés tôt
jeudi juin 44 ans était descendue à mon
copain et brassard doit l'appeler mieux
dorado est alors à ce moment là comme on
est en train de discuter
on entend un vomissement de moteurs 5e
ton mitrailleuses montées en braquant
leurs fusils mitrailleurs sur les gens'
du bourg alors moi ce moment là ne sais
pas j'ai eu peur je pense et qui venait
ramasser les jeunes de radeaux quand ils
ont été passées je suis remonté chez
nous et j'ai passé par le derrière du
bourne pour essayer d'arriver chez nous
sans qui voit où j'allais me suis
camouflé dans le grenier sous des
planches et j'ai attendu au bout d'un
moment mes parents sont montés en disant
il ya vérification de carte d'identité
il faut qu'en descente j'avais une soeur
qui rêve un an alors elle a demandé des
minima très mimi qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
alors mon père a dit blé ma foi il apte
à laisser
on verra bien alors là ils sont partis
j'ai regardé pas le vasistas ont été
cernés impossible de partir comme
j'arrivais sur la toiture alors là il ya
un groupe d'allemands qui est rentré à
la maison
ils ont fouillé partout ils ont renversé
la cuisinière les meubles ils ont tout
écrasé tout fouillé on ne réécrit le
véritable sauvage quoi écrit soit la
même chose mais non que je peux pas me
rappeler qu'il est partout partout
partout c'était une véritable muraille à
3m postule toujours de partir il y avait
un fusil mitrailleur devant un fusil
mitrailleur par derrière et impossible
de sortir les maisons commencé à brûler
chez nous j'ai encore eu de la chance
n'est ce pas parce que ça me brûlait pas
comme ça pollue beaucoup moins vite
qu'ailleurs
alors si passé un moment tellement tongs
redescendu vers le vers le bourg
caoutchouc brûlé y avait de la fumée
partout tu es pomper de l'eau j'ai
éteint le feu chez nous c'est sorti du
linge de hydra est sorti tout un tas de
trucs et là je suis partie supportions
du bourg neuf ans elle je me pose des
gens qui étaient là haut alors je dis je
redescends je vais essayer de sauver
quelque chose parce que j'ai dit en a
qui y auront besoin
draw de quelque chose alors je reviens
chez nous je ressors encore pas mal de
choses j'ai aperçu les allemands qui
remontait avec charger encore une
brouette que je transportais de l'autre
côté dans une espèce de recoins quoi ils
ont tiré une rafale de mitraillette
sûrement d'huîtres à gauche pas vous
dire exactement que j'entendais les
balles et alors je fais peut-être 50 m
de plus je trouve une vieille dame dans
du charles et de la valade qui
descendent et voir ses petits enfants ne
sait pas où il était passé elle s'est
mise à pleurer
je lui dit descendez pas iron man qui
viennent de tirer sur moi elle a dû à
moi ils ne veulent rien à faire elle
s'est peut-être maîtres de plus alors là
ils ont tué justement d'où je sortais
j'ai regagné la campagne était peut-être
cette 7h30 le soir s'est terminé comme
sage après vous savez on ne pensait plus
à ces mêmes parce qu'on faisait quoi il
était traqué on avait peur de tout ce
qui remet ont passé des nuits c'était
pour un teint le 10 juin 44 j'étais dans
le roi d'or s'est éteint samedi en congé
chez mes parents à deux heures
l'après-midi les allemands sont arrivés
avec des voitures blindées jamais le
camarade monsieur brisseau que vous
venez de voir un instant qu'ils étaient
avec moi la peur même en fin puisque ça
tout au moins moi j'avais l'habitude
temps est à l'image de les voir assez
couramment
je suppose qu'ils ont laissé des hommes
pour cerner le village et ils sont
redescendus pour nous faire aller sur la
place du champ de foire
là j'étais au rassemblement avec ma mère
et deux soeurs le parmi les allemands
qui étaient sur le champ de foire
il y en avait une beaucoup de jeunes
gens roanne qui sentait d'une maison une
boîte de sucre
d'ailleurs le même je les retrouvais
dans la grotte où ils m'ont mitraillé
images et le sucre à poigne et monsieur
compagne pâtissier
10 est allemand qui était vraiment petit
son fusil dépasser sans son casque
elle veut donner peut-être 14 ou 15 ans
il a dit est-ce que je peux aller voir
mes gâteaux qui vont brûler que
l'allemande a répondu aux français pas
embrasé mais il a répondu en français on
n y était pas s'occupera de vos gâteaux
ils ont séparé du groupe les femmes les
enfants environ à l'âge de 14 ans les
enfants aller avec eux les maires au
dessus on considérait que c'était des
hommes
moi j'avais 19 ans sylla est dans le
groupe des hommes ils ont fait partir
les femmes d'abord nous les hommes on
nous a mis sur la place face au mur un
rempart trois là j'avoue que j'ai eu
peur
ils ont demandé au maire de désigner des
otages est gelée très bien entendu dire
j'ai mes enfants et moi-même je n'ai pas
ça ne désignez de plus nous ont dit à un
dépôt de munitions qui était faux parce
qu'ils n'ont rien changé du tout on a
tous été plus ou moins surpris ça et
quand on habite un village comme moi où
je suis né et on connaît tout le monde
et toutes les maisons pas une
vraiment on était sûr qu'il n'y ait pas
de dépôts de munitions il ya plusieurs
personnes qui ont dit moi j'ai gardé mon
fusil de chasse l'autre on dit j'ai une
carabine
ils nous ont dit non non ça ne nous
intéresse pas parce que j'ai oublié de
vous dire il y avait un interprète quand
même qui parlait très bien très bien le
français qui nous poser ces questions
qui nous ont dirigés vers le centre du
bourg
des camarades qui sont tournés vers la
droite signoret with année et alors nous
les parties de dernier on a été faire un
détour et on est revenu dans le gard
l'aude y avait une charrette fait
enlever à présent pré emballé sont bien
nettoyer l'emplacement
ils ont mis en batterie de fusils
mitrailleurs on était tous les jeunes
ressemblent à celles qui étaient passés
par le bond de refaire on passait pas ce
qui allait nous arriver
ce qui nous intéressait c'était le
football match du lendemain
et à ce moment là il ya eu une très
forte détonation dans le bourg et on
nous a fait lever parce qu'on était
assis avec du fouet un petit peu tour
nous a fait lever que tout le monde soit
debout et à ce moment là j'avais
camarades qui étaient alsaciens et
confondre l allemand qui était juste à
côté de moi et qui m'a dit attention il
y a ils n'ont même pas fini sa phrase et
à ce moment là qu'on a tiré sur nous
plusieurs rafales de fusils mitrailleurs
et quand tu as eu tir et ils ont fait le
tour des cadavres puis achevé tout ce
qu'ils voyaient et tiré à coups de
revolver ou à coups de mitraillette tiré
là par le tap que j'étais blessé
c'est un à chevannes mes camarades qui
avait sa tête sur ma jambe
ils ont tiré une balle de revolver dans
la tête m'a touché à la jambe après ils
nous ont couvert deux fois de fagots
tout ce qu'ils avaient dans la grande
qu'à ce moment là je pense qu'ils sont
partis parce que les biens restés
difficiles à évoluer dans des cas
pareils mais ça a été long me semble un
bon quart d'heure on les entendait pas
absolument pas j'ai entendu un poste
radio qui marchait qui l'a ému très très
fort dans une maison à côté
tout le monde était blessé mais je pense
qu'il n'y avait pas beaucoup de morts ce
qui nous on tirait très très bas à ce
moment là ils ont mis le fin quand ça me
fait vraiment ça va brûler tous les
chemins sont mauvais
brûler le bras gauche à ce moment là
j'ai pris la décision de partir j'ai
préféré me faire tuer d'une balle que de
mourir par le feu monsieur goury qui
étaient valides qui a fait une brèche
dans le mur de cette grange
ce qui nous a permis de passer dans une
deuxième rage où il y avait la paille et
au moment où on arrive et les allemands
ouvert la porte
moi je le temps de mes talons sur une
pile de fagots ils ont pris l'échelle
qui était à côté de ce tas de fagots
l'allemand est monté si j'arrête
indûment moi je touche et son casque eu
la chance qu'ils se retournent pas de
mon côté il avait sa mitraillette en
bandoulière il a craqué deux allumettes
pour mettre le feu
où étaient mes camarades c'est à dire
dans tout non oui il y avait partout
robbie et bruce odier qui était de soul
et le tas de toriko coin de santé ils
ont tiré dans le 3d va l'incendiaire la
grange a pris feu tout de suite et son
parti et après quand on a pu sentir on
appris des clapiers à côté ou dans tous
souffraient vraiment l'été à ce moment
là déjà et 6h30 et 7h et allons là il a
fallu prendre une décision c'était de
traverser la place de l'autre côté du ch
avait eu une petite pente qui rentre
dans un jardin mais devant cette pente
on avait des branches pour faire des
fûts il avait bien d'émettre deux mètres
cinquante de long fallait qu'on escalade
qui nous attendait que surtout pour ceux
qui étaient blessés et avec dart où on
est restés les deux derniers dans le
clapier il avait énormément de fier le
donnait à boire l'eau des poussées un
coup aux mouchoirs une trempette dans et
moi je suis parti après je lui ai dit au
roi regret je suis parti là l'an dernier
et dans tout me suivit tout de suite
après il a réussi à traverser et puis il
est resté dans le jardin derrière où il
a passé l'année inception domaine avec
ma famille
le temps était mauvais ce jour là c'est
pour ça qu'on nous a trouvés à la maison
et quand nous avons vu monter les chars
mon mari a connu qu citer les allemands
il dit
si vous me croyez nous ferions bien de
partir de nous tirer de la vie personne
n'a bougé
personne n'a bougé et entre temps il y
avait des militaires qui s'est détachée
qui sont venus à travers champs et qui
nous ont pris à la maison en nous disant
tous place du marché et en effet il a
fallu se rendre ici sur un champ de
foire j'ai pas besoin de vous dire
l'émotion qu'on a eu et la peur et après
une longue attente à nous à séparer les
hommes des femmes
nous avons été conduits à l'église et
les hommes ont été mis dans les granges
le moment le plus pénible c'est quand il
a fallu se séparer
mon fils ne pourrais pas me lâcher que
mon cou les petites c'était pareil on
avait conduit les enfants des écoles
jusqu'ici entourés de leurs maîtres
évidemment certains avaient leur maman
mais c'est des villages ne l'avait pas
alors tout le monde des partis encadré
avec les allemands
oh je fus comme fou dans le premier
moment hélas
et je pleurais trois jours amène à vous
tous à qui dieu pris votre chère
espérance père
merde
dont la masse ou faire ma souffrance
tout ce que j'éprouvais la veille vous
éprouvez
je voulais me briser le front sur le
pavé puis je me révoltait et par moments
terribles je fixe à mes regards sur
cette chose horrible je n'y croyais pas
et je mets criait non est ce que dieu
permet de ses malheurs sans nom qui font
que dans le coeur le désespoir se lève
il me semblait que tout n'était qu'un
affreux rêve qu'elle ne pouvait pas
m'avoir ainsi quitté que je l'entendais
rire en la chambre à côté que c'était
impossible enfin qu'elle fût morte et
que j'allais la voir entrer par cette
porte
[Musique]
or que le foie jeudi silence est la part
des tenues
voici le bruit de sa main sur la clé
attendez elle vient laissez-moi que
j'écoute car elle est quelque part dans
la maison sans doute
[Musique]
elle avait pris se plieront son âge
enfantin de venir dans ma chambre un peu
chaque matin je n'attendais ainsi qu'un
rayon qu'on espère elle entrait et
disait bonjour mon petit père prenez ma
plaine ou vrai mais lire s'asseyait sur
mon lit déranger mes papiers est rien
puis soudain sont allés comme un oiseau
qui passe alors je reprenais la tête un
peu moins l'asthme en oeuvre interrompu
et tout en écrivant parmi mes manuscrits
je rencontrais souvent quelques
arabesques folle et qu'elle avait tracé
et maintenance blanche entre ses mains a
froissé ou je ne sais comment venait
mais plus d'ouvert
l aimer dieu les fleurs les astres les
prêts verts et c'était un esprit avant
d'être une femme
son regard refléter la clarté de son âme
elle ne consultait surtout à tout moment
que deux soirs d'hiver radieuse et
charmant passé à raisonner langues
histoire et grammaire mes quatre enfants
groupe et sur mes genoux leur mère tout
près quelques amis causant au coin du
feu
j'appelais cette vie être content de peu
[Musique]
et dire que le mort
et la seule
que dieu maciste je n'étais jamais
ganges lasseront et ariste jeter morne
au milieu du bal le plus joyeux
si j'avais en partant vu quelques ombres
ont saisi
[Musique]
où
e
non
[Musique]
on
et
à
oh
[Musique]
vous
pour arriver dans cette église
on avait déposé une caisse sur deux
chaises
d'où sortaient des corps d'hommes
évidemment tout le monde se demandait ce
qui allait nous arriver
moi j'ai dit à une personne des bruyères
j'ai dit vous voyez ça j'ai dit c'est
une bonne nous allons tous sauté avec
une église qu elle me dit ne parlez pas
de ça et de fêter cette boîte a explosé
on s'est plus vu dans ça nous a étouffés
les gens 6 tout noir nous nous sommes
réfugiés dans la sacristie avec mes
filles ma fille aînée avait perdu son
petit bébé elle l'a retrouvé
mais je ne sais pas s'il était mort ou
vivant et au dernier moment le plancher
à craquer de la sacristie
à ce moment là moi je suis sorti un
sortant je me suis caché derrière le
maître-autel
et c'est de là que j'ai sauté par la
fenêtre mais ma fille la plus jeune
était tuée d'une balle dedans dehors
quant à l'autre les nazis pour les
vivent alors évidemment j'ai couru dans
ce jardin en arrivant dans ce jardin
j'ai été mitraillé j'ai tendu on m'a
laissé pensant sans doute que j'étais
morte
ce n'est que dans l'ami que je pensais
partir
mélanie était tellement éclairé par les
incendies il y avait un militaire qui
faisait de la moto la moto de monsieur
avril là il a roulé qu'en qu'il a plus
qu il ya eu de licence et après il l'a
jetée dans la glâne le lendemain au
petit jour je pensais man aller mais je
n'ai pas pu me rendre c'est j'avais eu
les cymbales de la mitraillette
j'ai lu la cuisse traversée l'omoplate
fendu en deux les deux jambes remis
taille et donc j'y suis resté en
attendant des secours
et ce n'est que le dimanche vers le soir
que j'ai entendu marché j'ai appelé au
secours
ces gens se sont arrêtés et j'ai
retourné appelé comme ça trois fois au
secours en disant je suis dans les
petits pois et on m'a trouvé c'était de
métayers de madame la vicomtesse de ces
morts qui sont allés chercher une boîte
pour remettre dedans et qui ment conduit
au château de l'applaudir j'ai reçu les
premiers soins
douter consommer oradour n'est plus
le feu partout tente d'effacer
l'indélébile crime mais comme dans la
chair et dont le sang dans la pierre et
dans la terre a jamais est inscrit
l'immense l'inoubliable forfait
[Musique]
et
e
objet dérisoire témoin de tant de
souffrances dont l'eau est bien léger
pour 642 victimes
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
oui aura deux jours
il convient d'honorer ton souvenir par
respect pourtant d'innocentés victimes
vous mordre à 12 vous êtes des
bâtisseurs au côté des vivants
dans votre sacrifice ont germé à nouveau
la paix la douceur de vivre
et aujourd'hui après tant d'années sur
un mur de votre cité meurtrie accroché
au caire disjointes une vigne témoin de
tant d'exactions donne encore comme par
le passé ses fruits denrées de lumière
gorgés de soleil comme le symbole d'une
terre qui ne veut et ne peut pas mourir
[Musique]